Fletcher: Well,
good day, everyone.
Luke:
Are we on?
Fletcher:
Yes, we're on, Luke.
Luke:
Cool.
Fletcher:
My name's Jess Fletcher.
Mahe:
And I'm Luke Mahe.
Fletcher: And we're
from the Maps API team
based in Sydney, Australia.
Mahe: Welcome to this talk about
Designing Maps Applications
for Usability on
Mobile and Desktop.
So, a little housekeeping?
Fletcher: A little bit
of housekeeping.
You've probably seen this
in all the talks you've been to
this morning.
There's a link here
to SpeakerMeter,
so we can get some feedback
from the audience on the talk.
You know, you might want
to talk about things
like Luke's haircut.
Mahe: It's pretty bad.
Fletcher: How fat he is,
you know, these sorts of things.
And of course these are
the twitter hashtags to use
for this session.
Mahe: So, cool?
Fletcher: Cool.
Mahe: All right.
So, a little overview
of what we're going to be
talking about today.
We'll talk a bit about
what is user experience.
Fletcher: Yeah, because we're
going to be talking about--
the title of the talk
is about usability,
but that's about how the user
actually experiences your site,
and we'll go into a little bit
of detail about what that means.
Mahe: Some of the differences
between desktop and mobile,
not just how people
interact with them,
but the fundamental differences
between the two.
Fletcher: Exactly.
So we're talking about use cases
and technical limitations
and so forth.
Mahe: And then we'll
talk a little bit
about the pain points.
What are some common things
you might run into,
and then hopefully
offer some suggestions
on how to fix it.
Fletcher: Exactly.
So this is going to be the
main thrust of our talk.
We're going to identify
a set of things
that people
can often do wrong
when it comes to
user experience.
And these are things
that can really make
the user experience suck.
And we want to identify them
and work through some ways
that you can mitigate.
Mahe: Yeah.
So first, like, Jess,
what is user experience?
Fletcher:
Well, user experience--
we're talking about
everything to do with the way
the user interacts
with your application.
So this is everything
from the user interface,
the way things are laid out,
how they actually
activate your site
and so forth like that.
But it's also
more subtle things,
and it's to do with
how your users actually go
about solving the problem that
they came to your site with.
Mahe: So, firstly,
it's about respecting
the intent of the user.
They've come to your site
for a reason,
and they may have a problem,
but you respect that
and will deliver them
a solution for it.
Fletcher:
Exactly.
They've come there expecting
to be able to do something,
and you have to respect that
and be able to give them
a solution, which takes us
to our next point.
Mahe: Yes.
Don't give them a problem.
Give them a solution.
Fletcher: Exactly.
They've already got a problem,
right?
That's why they're at your site.
You might have something,
you know,
you want to track ponies,
you want to do something else
with a mapping application,
right?
Mahe: But if they can't find
those ponies--
Fletcher: Then they've got
another problem, right?
And they've
already got a problem,
so you've got to give them
the solution to their problem.
Mahe: And ensure
that their experience matches
their mental model.
They have an idea in their mind
when they come to your site
of what they want,
and we should match that
and keep the experience flowing
for what they want.
Fletcher: Exactly, and this is
particularly important
for a mapping application,
because people have
pretty fixed ideas
about what they are
going to get into
when they've got
a mapping application.
And so you've
got to make sure
that you match up
with their expectations
and how they think about things
in their head,
with how they're actually
going to interact
with your application.
Mahe: And then it's about,
how does that intent relate
to a mapping application?
Fletcher: Right. So we've talked
a lot about intent now,
and we've talked about
respecting the intent
and making sure that we can
solve the problem of the user,
but we need to work out now
what we mean by intent
when we're talking about
a mapping application.
Mahe: Especially between
desktop and mobile.
Fletcher:
Exactly.
Mahe: So with that,
we should talk a bit about
what is desktop
and how is it used,
and some of the differences
between that and mobile.
Fletcher:
Exactly.
Mahe: So desktop is usually
used for planning.
You don't carry your desktop
around with you.
It's a bit big.
So, it's all about feeling out--
Fletcher:
I don't know, I've seen you
carrying your desktop around--
Mahe: Yeah,
that 30-inch monitor--
Fletcher: You were
probably stealing it.
Mahe: Yeah, well,
it was probably yours.
Fletcher:
Yeah, I think so.
I did miss my computer
for a while there.
Mahe:
So it's about planning.
It's about kind of figuring out
what you want to do.
You don't mind sifting
through information,
usually on a comfy couch.
You don't mind getting
a bit more sent to you
to evaluate the options,
and then kind of
make a decision.
Fletcher: Exactly. You've got
a lot more power with a desktop,
so you can show the user
a lot of different options,
and give them things
that they can evaluate.
Mahe: But then on mobile,
it's more about immediacy.
It's about now.
I'm out in the world,
walking around,
and I've got a question.
It's usually where I am.
You've got the context
that the phone can provide.
You know, the location
and that sort of stuff.
So, it's using that to enrich
their experience and solve that.
Fletcher: Exactly. And we're
moving here from a planning,
sort of passive stage when
you're on a desktop application,
to an active stage when you go
to the mobile device.
It's immediate.
It's about immediacy.
Mahe: Yeah, so
but those are just how you
kind of interact with the two,
but there are some
fundamental differences
between desktop and mobile.
Fletcher: Right,
and these are things that--
they're pretty simple things.
They're things
that you would think about
when you're thinking about
making a desktop app
compared to a mobile app.
But it's good to go
through them,
because often
it's really easy
to just overlook
one of these things,
and to make a site
that works great for a desktop
but just doesn't translate
at all for a mobile.
Mahe:
And these things are like,
whether the person is using
a mouse, or a touch device.
You know, you could use
mouse tool tips
when you hover over them.
You can change the cursor icon,
but you can't really do that
on a mobile device.
Fletcher: Exactly.
And it's things
like not expecting
that you're going to get
a mouse-over event
when you're clicking
on an item,
if a user
is using a touch device.
Mahe: Yeah.
Things like the screen size.
Obviously the screen sizes
vary dramatically
between desktop and mobile,
and the resolution as well.
Fletcher: Exactly.
And this is probably
the most fundamental thing.
It's about screen real estate.
You just don't have
as much space
to display things
on a mobile device.
And we'll go through
a number of examples
where that becomes apparent.
Mahe: Yeah, and then
bandwidth, obviously.
Phones, especially.
Here they have unlimited data,
but when you're in Australia,
it costs us money.
Fletcher: I know.
Mahe: So it's a bit rude
when you start sending me
5 meg images of ponies
on my phone.
Fletcher: And I have to
pay for that, you know.
Mahe: Yeah.
I know.
Fletcher: He keeps sending me
these photos of ponies
and you know,
it's just chewing
through my data quota
every month.
Mahe:
You like ponies.
Fletcher: I like ponies,
but not that much.
Not the amount you send me.
Mahe: That's a lot of ponies.
And then it's about location.
Your desktop does--
you can kind of get within a
city range, usually, on desktop,
but on a mobile, you can get to
within a couple of meters.
Fletcher:
And of course,
this takes us back
to our active versus
passive theme, right?
It's the use case and
the capabilities of a mobile.
Mahe: And then
processing power.
You find you usually have
a lot less,
so think about what you're going
to be doing on the phone,
what data you're going
to be sending down,
and then what you're
actually going to do with it
compared to what you can do
on the server.
Fletcher: So a key point
of our talk today is,
if you do things naively,
then you can actually
really hurt yourself when you go
to a mobile environment.
So something that might be
really nice,
have a lot of nice graphic
transitions and so forth
on a desktop,
might just slow down the phone
to the point
that it's not usable.
Mahe:
And lastly, cache.
You can't expect
someone on a phone
that's got a lot less cache
to have everything
that you sent to them
last time still there,
so it's kind of being smart
about what you store
on the phone,
what you send down,
and kind of thinking about
what you're doing.
Fletcher:
Okay, cool.
Mahe: So, Jess,
why do we care?
Fletcher:
Why do we care?
So, we've talked a lot,
we've given you a lot of
platitudes so far about,
you have to have
good user experience.
What user experience means,
and what are some of
the problems that--
the question is,
why do we care, Luke?
Mahe:
Because.
Fletcher: Wow. That's
not really an answer, is it?
Mahe: It's my answer
to everything.
Fletcher: It's your answer,
but you're kind of lazy,
and you don't really
have a good answer,
so I've got a better answer
for us.
Mahe: Okay,
how about this?
Fletcher: So, the answer is,
if the user experience sucks,
then the users aren't
going to come back.
Now, you might have
a really great site.
Like--
Mahe: Ponies.
Fletcher: Right.
Luke and his ponies site.
It might be the greatest
premise ever.
But if people can't actually
use that to track their ponies
or whatever they're
intending to do,
then they're not
going to come back.
They might go there,
trying to do this,
and they just get frustrated
with it, so they go,
"Well, I'm never
going back."
Mahe: And now they've got
another problem.
Fletcher: And now they've
got another problem.
Mahe: We don't want to
give them more problems.
Fletcher:
Exactly.
Mahe: So keeping that in mind,
we'll just be talking about--
you know, if it's done badly,
then the user experience sucks.
Fletcher: Okay, so we've got
to identify some things that,
if they are done badly,
we're going to make the users
frustrated.
We're going to make
the user experience suck.
Mahe: So, firstly,
the layout, Jess.
If the layout is done badly,
the user experience sucks.
Now, what do we kind
of mean by the layout?
Fletcher: Well, the layout is
probably the most obvious thing
you think of when you think
of user experience, right?
It's to do with how things
are put on the page,
how you actually
represent things,
and some of the problems
that a bad layout
can give you is clutter.
People don't like seeing
a cluttered webpage,
and so, if they
immediately see a theme
that has a million
different things,
controls all over the place,
and the map not set up the way
it's meant to be,
then they're going to get
frustrated.
Mahe: Yeah. And then,
kind of moving buttons
around and shifting
things between
when someone did something
and when they look at it
again.
You know, it's kind of just
being smart and being consistent
and doing
those sorts of things.
Fletcher: And so,
key things to think about
when you're thinking about
desktop versus mobile here.
On the desktop because you've
got the screen real estate,
you've got this space,
you can generally have the map
and the content that you want
to display on the map
all in the same place.
Mahe: And you can break out
the content.
You can display more,
you can give users
the ability to dive in
and kind of filter
and just expand and explore
their environment.
Fletcher:
And on mobile,
you really have to
make the choice, right?
You can have the map,
because you need the map
and you're
a mapping application,
but you've got to show
the content in a clever way
so that you're not
going to clutter up the map
when you're there.
And a classic example
of this,
and we'll have some examples in
a second, is the info window.
Mahe:
Yeah.
Fletcher: So, on a desktop,
an info window is a great way
to show context and content,
but on a mobile device,
it just really, really sucks.
Mahe: Yeah.
So, we'll show you that.
So, here is maps.google.com.
Fletcher: So, we're
using this as an example
of what we think
is a good user experience,
and we think maps.google.com
because you know, we work
for Google, so if we didn't,
we probably shouldn't
be giving this talk.
Mahe:
Yeah. Exactly.
So this is
maps.google.com.
You can see
it's the desktop version,
so we use up
the whole real estate.
You've got a big map,
kind of zoomed out so you can
see the whole world, because
you want to be able to explore.
So we've got room
for content on the left.
You've got the search file
always at the top,
and you've just got everything
kind of just spaced out nicely
so you can see
everything.
Fletcher: This is getting at
that kind of mental model thing.
This is how users expect to be
able to interact with the map.
Having the search bar
always available,
no matter what you're doing
with the map, is great
because, you know, that's
what people are there to do.
They're there to search;
they're there to
interact with it.
Mahe: So if we look at the same
thing on the mobile device,
it's kind of the same,
just a bit simplified.
Fletcher: A bit simplified.
And so what we see here is,
we've taken the map,
we've zoomed it in a lot
because we've got a lot more
context of course.
Mahe: We know where they are
so we might as well
just bring the map as close
as we can go,
because that way, they don't
have to send as much data,
they don't have to pan around
as much,
and we're just respecting
their intent.
Fletcher:
Exactly.
Mahe: And then
if we move along
to actually showing data
on the map,
you can see that we've got
the results on the left.
You can scroll up and down.
You can have more.
We've got the map
on the right;
we've got tool tips
when you hover over them.
It's just a lot more content.
Fletcher: And this is because
we're in this planning stage,
remember. We want to show
the users a lot of content.
We want to give them
a lot of options,
because they're evaluating
different alternatives
about what
they're trying to do.
Mahe: But if we move
this to the mobile,
because the content
is still there.
We did the search;
we found all our results.
They're there.
But we're just given more
options to get what we want
rather than having been
bombarded with everything.
Fletcher: Exactly. So let's
move to the info window example,
and we'll see here,
this is the classic info window.
It's great when you're
in the planning stage
because it's giving you a lot of
information very quickly.
Mahe: And it looks pretty.
Fletcher: It looks pretty.
We like the look of
that info window.
So we've got
the thumbnail there,
we've got a summary of
the review status, the website.
Mahe: Connects to the marker,
so you--
Fletcher:
It connects to the marker,
so you've got the context.
Mahe: Yeah.
Jesse:
Of course, you know.
And of course,
all of the results
still on
the left hand side there.
Mahe: And when we do
the same thing on the mobile,
you see, instead of filling
the whole screen
with an info window where
you can't kind of figure out
what you just clicked on,
we'll just pop it up
at the bottom.
You can relate it to the marker,
so we just clicked on B,
so we'll show B down below,
and because we're
in the active stage,
we're going to give options
of calling and giving directions
because that's more what
you're going to be doing.
Fletcher:
Exactly, this is about--
this is key about respecting
the intent of the user.
If someone's out
and they're searching
for a particular business,
one of the things
they're probably
likely to want to do
is to find the phone number
and call it.
Mahe:
Or get directions.
Fletcher:
Or get directions there.
Mahe: So moving on,
if the data representation
is done badly,
the user experience sucks.
Like, what do you mean
by that, Jess?
Fletcher: So this is
where we're adding value
to the map, right?
So this is
besides the map itself,
this is adding the content,
the information that you have,
that you want to display
graphically on the map.
And again, one of the key things
that can go wrong
if you do this badly
is clutter.
And this kind of
gets back to our concept
of doing things naively.
If you do things naively,
then you end up
making a sucky user experience.
Mahe: Yeah, like
showing too much data.
This is easy.
I like getting all my data
and putting it on the map
because I don't have to
think about it.
Fletcher:
I know. We already know
that you're lazy, right?
Mahe: So this is about
giving them the information
that they want.
We don't want to
load the entire world
and send it down to them,
if they're not really interested
in the entire world.
Fletcher: Exactly. And
the other key point you can do
when you're representing data
is breaking their mental model
of the data.
If they have
a particular expectation
about how this data
is going to be represented,
if you give them a really
weird way of doing that,
then they're going to be
disconnected with it,
and it's going to
frustrate them.
Mahe: So I've got
a little demo here.
This is a little project
I've been working on.
Do you know
what country this is?
Fletcher: Yeah,
that's Australia.
That's where we are.
Mahe: Yeah?
What do you reckon
of my little project?
Fletcher: See, I don't know
what to say, Luke.
That's just terrible.
What are we even
looking at there?
Mahe: This is every
public toilet in Australia.
Fletcher: Okay, so I can see
why you might need that data,
if you're potentially
in a hurry,
but that's just not useful
for me.
I'm looking at that,
and it's obstructing
the entire map.
You know,
what are you thinking?
Mahe:
Yeah, okay.
I suppose if we think about it
a little bit more,
we could do something
like this.
Fletcher: Okay, so this is
a bit more interesting, right?
This is showing us--
what's this showing us?
Mahe: This is essentially
clustering that information,
instead of just displaying
every marker in the world,
we'll just replace that
with just icons
that represent how much data
is there.
Fletcher: Okay.
Okay, cool.
So we can see that around
Sydney and so forth,
we've got about
3,500 public toilets.
Mahe: And you've visited
almost all of them.
Fletcher: Yeah.
It's very important to me.
So what if we want to just
show the relative concentration
of public toilets
around Australia?
Mahe: You think a bit more
like this?
Fletcher: Okay, cool.
So this is showing us--
what's this showing us, Luke?
Mahe:
This is using Fusion Tables
to just generate
a heat map instead,
so this is just
going to render some tiles.
It's much quicker
to send down to the browser
and we see much
more of a concentration
of the information.
Fletcher: So this is useful
if I want to see
what sort of areas
I need to hang around
if I need a lot of
public toilets around me.
Mahe:
Yeah.
And here's another project
I've been working on.
What do you think about it?
Fletcher: Okay, this is okay,
but what's this?
What's this doing?
Mahe: I like to track
zombies as well.
Fletcher:
You're tracking zombies.
Mahe: Yeah, so the hero
and my zombies,
and they're kind of
coming toward this mall.
Fletcher:
But I already have
a mental model of what
zombies are like, Luke,
and these aren't really
matching my mental model
of what a zombie looks like.
Mahe: Would this help?
Fletcher:
Ah, see, that looks better.
See, that's scary.
I wouldn't
necessarily be scared
if I just saw
a bunch of markers around.
I'd just think there was
a lot of Google I/Os--
Mahe: Giant marker
comes to eat your brains?
Fletcher:
Yeah, not scary.
I just think-- you know, yeah.
Okay. But this is a lot better;
this is matching more up
with my expectations.
I've been working on
a similar site;
it's for tracking ninjas.
That was a really big laugh,
and I'm actually kind of
disappointed we got a laugh,
because we used the exact
same joke in our talk last year.
So obviously people weren't
paying attention last year,
or they haven't watched
on Youtube.
Mahe: Yeah.
So moving on.
If controlling the map
is done badly,
the user experience sucks.
Fletcher: See, this is
getting very negative, Luke.
Mahe: I'm not a negative
person, man.
Fletcher: You're not
a negative person,
but you're being very--
you're talking about sucking
and doing things badly.
Can we maybe
switch it up a bit?
Mahe: All right.
What if we do this?
If the controlling the map
is done well,
the user experience rocks.
Fletcher: All right,
all right.
Let's make the user
experience rock.
Mahe: That's what
we're here for.
Fletcher: Okay.
So controlling the map.
This is actually how the user
interacts with the map itself.
And this is really getting
at matching up
with people's expectations.
There are a lot of
mapping sites out there,
but they all have
a sort of similar way
of interacting with the map,
how you can actually do things,
and if you break them into
a model of how to do this
and their expectations,
then it's going to really suck.
And I'm still talking negative.
Mahe: Yeah.
Fletcher: If you do it right,
it's going to rock.
Mahe: It will rock.
And this isn't saying
that you don't have to
design something cool,
and just follow
what everyone does.
It's just thinking about
what people are used to,
and kind of--you can make
things kind of cool and better,
but you don't want to make
people really think too hard
about what they have to do,
because then it's just going to
become more of a problem
than it's actually--
Fletcher:
This is simple things,
things like making
the interactions obvious.
Make it obvious what you can
actually interact with.
Making your controls
consistent,
that's particularly the case
for a mobile device,
where you don't have cues
like you know,
if you mouse over something
and the hand turns into a click.
Mahe: Yeah.
And it's stuff like having
all the buttons the same size,
so you know just by
visually looking at it
what is a button
and what isn't.
And you're making them bigger
so you can touch it
with your finger,
or with your dialing wand.
Fletcher: And I have
really, really fat fingers
so I need a dialing
wand for mine.
Mahe: And it's things like
removing functionality.
You don't want to remove
functionality.
You just want
to simplify it.
Fletcher: And that goes back
to naivety again, right?
People often build
a great desktop application,
and then to make
a mobile version,
they just rip out the guts
of the application, right?
They make it
a lot simpler.
But they've actually removed
a lot of the stuff
that you can do
in the desktop app,
and you don't want to
do that.
Mahe: Yeah, you don't want to
dumb it down.
You just want to simplify.
Fletcher: Exactly.
Mahe: So here's again
the maps example.
We're going to use this
quite a bit.
On the desktop version,
we have the map type
controller on top,
where you hover over
and it expands out.
A lot of people
have seen that.
We've got the overview map
control down at the bottom
and we've got a slider
for the nav.
We've got all these cool things
we can interact with,
and we don't have to be told
to interact with it, do we?
We can just kind of
explore the interface.
Fletcher: Exactly.
And make it easy
for the user to explore it.
Mahe: And then on mobile you see
we've got bigger buttons.
We can just look at this,
and easily see what's a button,
and what isn't.
What we can kind of
interact with.
Fletcher: Exactly.
The key point is
that we've got
a consistent scheme
for everything that the user
can interact with.
So it's easy
to drag the map around,
because that's
kind of intuitive,
but then all of the buttons,
they're styled the same way.
They're really obvious
that these are buttons;
these are something you can
click on with your dialing wand.
Mahe: So, responsiveness.
This is a key thing.
If the responsiveness
is done well,
the user experience rocks.
Fletcher: And this is
getting into something
that people might often overlook
in terms of usability.
Mahe:
So it's, again,
it's about not breaking
the mental model.
If you're panning a map
with a touch device,
if you suddenly start doing
all this computation
and just doing
lots of weird things,
it just won't feel like
it's sticking to your hand.
And people just
will get kind of confused
about what they're doing.
Fletcher: Exactly.
A map is a physical thing
in people's minds, right?
And so if you're
dragging it around,
especially on a tablet device,
it feels really good
when it actually interacts
with your fingers
the way it's meant to, right?
And if you have
a lot of latency,
if you have a lot of delay,
if you have a lot of lag
in the way it does,
then it really breaks
people's mental model,
and it really,
really frustrates them.
Mahe: So we have a couple
of demos that show this.
So here's a common thing
that we've seen people use.
They'll put all the data
on a map,
and then when someone
pans around,
they'll get rid of every marker
and then load it
and put it back, and you kind of
just forget what's happening.
So we'll pan the map,
and see the markers disappear,
pop in, when you move
a little bit.
So there was a marker
on the left,
and I'm kind of
confused and scared.
Fletcher: So this is when you're
re-querying your data
to update it when a user
drags a map,
which you might want to do,
because you want to
show the new data
where the user has
dragged and so forth.
Mahe: But then, instead,
doing some simple things,
like keeping the markers
around
and then just getting
rid of them
when they're not
in the screen anymore.
This just feels like a much more
fluid interaction with it.
I can see the markers.
If I go too fast so
that nothing is there,
I can go back
and they're still there
and it just feels better.
Fletcher: It feels better.
And this is
another example.
This is putting
an overlay onto the map
and this is a great image
I found of the 15th century,
Augsburg in Germany.
Mahe: How big
is this image, Jess?
Fletcher: That's about 5 MB,
and I just found it--
I decided, "Yeah, I'm going
to plonk that on the map,
and it's going
to be great-- "
Mahe: But it doesn't work
too well.
Fletcher: But it's just really
laggy when you drag it around.
So you've got to make sure
that--
and of course you're taking up
our Australian bandwidth too,
if you do this.
Don't do that.
Mahe: Yeah. And I've got to use
that bandwidth to find ponies.
Fletcher:
Yeah, exactly.
So instead,
what you can do,
make sure that you get
your overlays
to the proper resolution,
a resolution
that you can actually render.
And this one,
we're actually using KML
to render this as well.
Mahe: Yeah.
So that just moves
a lot better.
It's a lot more easy
to interact with.
I don't feel like
I'm waiting for something.
Fletcher:
Exactly.
Mahe: So, a good shout out
to "Speedy Maps".
Fletcher:
Good shout out.
So, there's a great talk on
tomorrow morning at 10:00 am,
straight after the keynote,
which is going to go
into this particular thing
about making your map speedy,
about making it responsive,
adding a lot more detail.
Mahe:
Yeah, going right down
to the like the dawn level
sort of thing.
Fletcher: Exactly.
So go check it out.
Mahe: So if the storage
is done well,
the user experience rocks.
And I mean, people don't
really think of storage
when it comes to user
experience, Jess.
Fletcher: But storage--
I mean, you've got data
that you're representing
that you're putting on the map,
and if you do it badly,
there are a lot of things
that can go wrong.
So we want to make sure that
we're using reliable sources
for our data,
using a reliable infrastructure
to put our data on the map
and so forth.
So we're going to take you
through some examples
of Google infrastructure
that is great for serving
and storing your data.
And so you can make
the user experience rock.
Mahe: Yeah. So stuff
like reliability,
always having your data up,
if someone's put data
on your site,
for them to be able to
get it back, you know,
if they put something there.
If they refresh the page,
they kind of
expect it to be there.
Fletcher: Exactly.
Latency, of course.
If you have your data honed in
a single database in Reykovic,
then it's not going to be very
useful outside Iceland, right?
Mahe: Unless
there's a volcano.
Fletcher: Unless
there's a volcano. Right.
Well, that's going to be
even worse, right?
Then everyone else
in the world
is going to start looking at
your site, your Icelandic site.
Mahe: You had one that was
about--what was it called?
Fletcher: The volcano.
Mahe: Yeah.
Fletcher: Yeah, you pronounced
it the other day.
Mahe: It had seven days in it,
that's all I know.
Fletcher: And of course,
editability.
So if you want to have
your data editable,
then there's some key things
you can do
to get that up and running.
Mahe: Yeah.
So, we like
Google products.
We thought we'd use
a couple of Google products
in these examples.
What was this one, Jess?
Fletcher: So this is
really simple example.
This is just serving some KML
directly from App Engine.
And this is just serving
a static KML file.
But once you've got the
harnessing power of App Engine,
you can actually do
a lot of cool things.
You can actually
write an application
to source data from users
and so forth like that,
and then serve it in a way
as KML or as JSON
or however you like,
so you can actually
render it on a map.
Mahe: And I've been talking
about my pony trackers
and here it is.
Okay.
Fletcher: Yeah,
cool, all right.
So this is an example
of editability,
if you've got
a crowd-sourced solution.
And App Engine might be
a bit heavyweight
for what you're interested in.
Mahe: Yeah.
So with this I've just used
Google Spreadsheets,
and it has a JSON feed callback,
so you can query a database
on a spreadsheet
for some data,
and it will come back in JSON,
and then you can put it
on the map.
And you said you saw a pony
the other day.
Fletcher: I did, I did see
a pony the other day.
Mahe:
Where did you see it?
Fletcher:
It was at Bondeye Beach.
I don't know why
I was at Bondeye Beach,
because I'm not a British
backpacker, but you know.
Occasionally
native Sydney-siders
do actually go to Bondeye Beach,
believe it or not.
Mahe: There you go,
is that where it is?
Jess; Yeah, great, okay,
so this is fantastic.
This is adding a row
to a spreadsheet,
and then we're querying
that to get the location.
Mahe: Yeah, and Spreadsheets
is really easy
for people to interact with,
and kind of nice,
a really simple solution.
So you know,
I know you didn't like
my toilet tracker that much,
so I made a better version
for you, Jess.
Do you like this?
Fletcher: Oh, okay.
So, what's this doing, Luke?
Mahe: So this is just querying
Fusion Tables--
base, username,
radius, search.
And I can just say,
given this point
and within this radius of this,
go query all the toilets.
Fletcher:
Cool.
Mahe: Pretty easy for you
when you're at the pub.
Fletcher:
Fantastic.
Because you know, I often
need to run off very quickly.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
And the great thing about
Fusion Tables of course,
is the geospacial query.
Mahe: Yes.
You can just put
all your data up there
and just query it, and then--
easy and simple.
Fletcher:
Of course.
Mahe: So if your sharing
is done well,
the user experience rocks.
Fletcher: Cool.
So let's talk a bit
about sharing
and what we actually
mean by sharing.
So it's not just--
so you think about sharing,
you think about
sharing something
that you've created
with other people.
But it's also sharing
between devices as well.
Mahe: With yourself.
Fletcher: Exactly.
Mahe:
So if you're on the desktop,
and you've done something,
and then you go,
you want to share it
with your phone
and go between the planning
and active stage.
Fletcher:
Absolutely.
Mahe: So it's then being able
to go to your website,
or go to your mapping
application,
interact with it,
kind of save your space,
wherever you were,
and share it on Gmail
or buzz or any other
social tool out there.
Fletcher: And of course,
once you've done that--
once you can
share it with devices,
you can also share it
with other people.
You know, this is about
planning as well.
It's about interactive
and sharing it
wherever else
you can share it.
Mahe: So, here's an example
that's quite common.
You were going to find
your backpackers in Sydney
down at Bondeye Beach.
So if you're on the desktop,
you kind of did a query.
You may have just dragged it
around to go across to--
Fletcher: Right, well see,
but I'm looking here.
You know,
I want to change this,
because this is going
by the cross-city tunnel,
and the cross-city tunnel
is really, really expensive.
It's like, $7 to use
the cross-city tunnel.
Mahe:
Which is like, $30 US now?
Fletcher: Yeah I think so,
$30 or $40, something like that.
So, you know, we might have
manipulated this a bit,
and we want to send
the exact directions
we found
during the planning stage
and send them
to our mobile device,
so when we get
the active stage,
we get something
like this again.
Mahe:
Yeah, like this.
So, as I said, you've got
your map and your content.
You can kind of switch back
between the two,
and it's gone
to the active phase.
We can easily
change the directions.
We're out in the world.
We can kind of see
where we are,
but it's just going
between the two,
not changing the experience,
just making it better
for the devices.
Fletcher:
Exactly
Mahe: So we'll give
another shout-out.
Fletcher: So, we were
going to talk a bit
about social sharing
and things like that,
but there's a much better talk
about it tomorrow afternoon.
Location based
app development,
and this is using the recently
announced Places API.
Mahe:
Yeah.
So that's really going to be
really interesting.
Fletcher: At 3pm tomorrow.
Go check it out.
Mahe: So, if map styling
is done well,
the user experience rocks.
Fletcher: Okay, and we can't
really talk about map styling,
or--we could,
but we have someone way better
to talk about map styling.
So, we'd like to invite
Justin up here
to talk about that issue.
Mahe: And he's going to talk
about how styling the map well
can give a great
user experience.
Justin:
Good job, good job.
You guys did a great job.
I don't know how I'm going to
top that up here all alone.
As they said,
if the controls are bad,
the user experience sucks.
If the sharing is bad,
if the storage is bad,
if it's not responsive,
the user experience sucks.
But if the styling is bad,
it's also going to suck.
It's going to suck a lot.
So what I want to talk about
is how to style maps,
specifically if
you're styling a map
for the purpose of
data overlays, a mashup,
anything like that,
how you want to style it
so that your users know
what the map is about.
And this, it's kind of written
as a companion piece
to this post
that I wrote in October.
I don't know if any of you
are familiar with it,
but I explained
different options you have
with the different styling,
and there are a lot of
samples here
if you want ideas for styling
or if you want to know
kind of what you can do,
this is a good starting point.
But we're going to go ahead
and to summarize that article,
there are basically three things
you can do to Google maps.
You can remove things,
usually piece by piece.
You can remove everything
if you want.
You can remove different
select things.
You can simplify
a couple of things,
but that's mainly limited to
the roads and also the cities.
And you can also pretty much
change the color of everything,
which I don't always
recommend that you do,
but you can.
So the goal of all
this is your data.
It's not really the map.
If you're overlaying data,
you want your data to be front
and center.
You don't want unnecessary
map elements in the way.
You want to show off
your data.
So I want to show some examples
of some really good mashups
that the styling
was really effective
at putting the data forward.
These first styles
mainly removed map elements
or they simplified them.
So my first example is a mashup
called Map-loid.
And that sounds
very strange.
What that is,
is if you go to the site,
this is the number of jobs
currently available
in each state, and I don't know
how they know that,
but they have jobs,
and it looks like Texas
has the most jobs right now,
so if you're unemployed,
you might want to run there.
But what's good about this
is how much they removed.
So let's look closely
at the map,
and you see the data,
and you see the outlines
of the states.
The whole point of this site
is just to show you
how many jobs
there are in each state.
So if they had left all this on,
you wouldn't--
it's not as clear.
They made it
much more effective,
much better presentation,
removing things
like cities, roads.
I don't think there's park names
on that one.
But it's very effective.
It's much easier to read without
all that stuff on the map.
Now there's-- the next example
here is this beautiful,
beautiful example from
the New York Times
that they did
for the 2010 census here
in the United States.
On this map here,
this is the population change
from the year 2000
to the year 2010.
The blue counties are counties
that gained population,
and the kind of tan counties
are counties
that lost population.
Like the Map-loid mashup,
they removed a significant
amount of the data on the map.
Cities, roads--
all that's out of the way,
so you can get a great picture
of the data.
The data is front and center,
and that's what you see.
There's nothing getting
in the way of it.
If you zoom in,
still the data.
It looks beautiful,
nothing really in the way.
And then,
as you keep zooming in,
cities are added
for reference points,
but there's no highways because
who's going to be using this
to find driving directions
to Grandma's house?
No one. This is a map of
population change,
so you don't need that.
It's really beautiful.
You zoom in a little more,
roads show up,
but they're simplified.
These are the simplified roads;
they don't have casings.
There's no signage
for the roads,
there's no highway shields,
there's no text.
It's all very plain, so that
the data can come forward.
Here side by side, what Google
maps normally looks like,
and what
their mashup looks like,
and you can kind of see
all that they took off.
It's really stunning.
Data's just front and center.
Now one more mashup
I want to show you,
and this is the prettiest one.
This is-- it's
Trulia's price reduction map.
It's real estate prices,
and how quickly they fell.
And with this,
they removed everything,
everything except
the state boundaries
and the lakes and oceans,
and it is gorgeous.
It's a really pretty map.
The data's just
front-and-center.
It leaves a very memorable,
compelling impact
on anybody who sees it.
And instead of having city names
or anything like that on here,
it's just divided
into zip code tracks,
and you simply hover over,
and you can see the information,
you can locate your city.
And they've also put
a search dialogue up there
that you can use to jump
to a certain city.
But this is really beautiful,
really compelling.
Now let's talk a little bit
about changing colors,
which this is very easy
to abuse,
but I'm going to show you some
masterful examples of this.
The first one I want to show you
is also from the New York Times.
They seem to have a really good
graphic department over there.
This one is regarding ethnicity
populations within urban areas.
Or actually, I think
it's of the whole US.
The dots on the map,
the different color dots,
signify the different
ethnicities,
and they have muted
everything on this map,
so that the only color you see,
other than the water of course,
are the ethnicities.
You don't see anything here.
You don't see parks;
you don't see anything of color.
The roads aren't colored,
nothing.
You see the data.
It's very clear.
Easy to make patterns,
easy to browse.
It's really beautiful.
One more shot, and the impact
that it has is just amazing.
if they had colored the roads,
you wouldn't see--
the data would not stand out
as much.
One more example,
and all the gray,
it really works well.
This is a different mashup.
This is from
the Wall Street Journal.
This is their guide
to the New York marathon,
and it was also a guide
to the San Francisco, Chicago,
and Boston marathons.
What they did here
is they took the roads
and they made them all white
so that the path of the marathon
is incredibly clear here.
You see the whole path.
There's nothing
competing with it.
Here's their map of
the San Francisco marathon.
And it's just--
there's nothing there,
getting in the way.
You see really clearly
where the path of this is.
Really well done.
Now, this technique
is very widespread.
Google uses it
in their own bicycle maps.
When you turn the bicycle layer
on, all the roads turn white,
and the bike paths and trails
are overlaid in green.
It allows you to see
very clearly
where all the bicycle paths are.
If you're making a mashup
of any kind of trail,
any kind of route,
anything like that,
consider making the roads--
if your mashup isn't important
for automobile navigation--
consider making the roads
all white,
because the impact
is really good.
I want to share with you
just a couple of tips
that may help improve some
mashups you may be working on,
or may be working on
in the future.
The first tip is don't be afraid
to take stuff off the map.
I'm serious about this.
Don't be afraid to.
Case in point:
this mashup here.
I ran into this mashup for
the first time the other day.
It's a weather mashup,
and what it's doing here
is there are little boxes there
with temperature numbers
in them.
But it's very hard
when you look at this
to see the temperature numbers
because the route numbers on.
And you see
the route numbers,
and it competes with
the temperature numbers.
You can't really
glance at this map
and see the temperatures
without also seeing the roads.
There's all these numbers
on here
kind of looking you in the face,
and you've got to really discern
what's a temperature
and what's a route number.
Don't be afraid to take stuff
off the map.
I don't think anybody's going
to be using this temperature map
to find their way home
or to find directions
to Google IO in San Francisco
or anything remotely like that.
Another example
from the same site is these--
I don't know
if you can even see them.
They're these
white labels.
They made the labels for
the parks on this map white,
which I thought was
a very unusual decision.
You can barely read it,
and I just wonder
instead of making them
white like that,
why not just
take the parks off?
I mean,
it's a weather map.
I don't know how important
the parks would be.
I mean, obviously cities
should be left on,
but the parks, I don't know.
Very hard to read.
However, one point
I want to make with this
is don't hesitate
to remove the maps' roads
if your mashup has nothing
to do with navigation.
The roads always seem to set
kind of the color for the map.
If the roads are red,
your map will kind of look pink
from far away.
If your roads
are yellow or orange,
your map will kind of
look yellow from far away,
and that will compete
with your data,
especially depending
on what color it is.
Here's a good example,
here.
This map has clearly no roads,
and it doesn't need them.
It's simply for showing
employment information,
or the number of jobs
in all these states.
That was a good decision
to leave them off.
But you have to be
very careful.
These are examples
that I'm going to show you
of things that I've
actually seen in the wild,
which is very perplexing.
Here's the first one.
Yeah.
And there was data on top
of here, so kind of confusing.
Let's go to another one.
I guess you're supposed
to find the cities
based on how big
the dots are.
I mean, I can kind of tell
where Sacramento
and San Francisco are,
but this was a hard one
to follow.
I can't remember
what data they had on it,
but it was--
I don't know.
I've seen this
quite a few times.
I don't know.
Maybe there was a reason.
This one, too.
I think this one
I've seen the most.
So this, by the way,
this is what not to do.
Just so you users
can understand your map.
Another thing that I want
to encourage you to do
is to sketch out your ideas.
It helps me a lot, you know.
Play with it.
Play around with your ideas.
This is a good tool
for doing that.
I don't know how many of you
are familiar with this,
but you can manipulate
the little map there,
change all sorts of things.
You could take everything off,
change the colors.
There's also another tool
that I like to use.
This one allows you to do it
full-screen.
If you want to see what the map
would look like
taking up the whole screen,
this is actually
a good solution.
This is scribblemaps.com.,
and you'll be--
as soon as you land
on this site,
you'll see this dialogue box
right there.
You press on the style map,
and there'll be a dialogue.
You can basically do anything
with the map.
Take everything off;
put everything on;
make all the roads
look like Skittles.
Whatever you want to do.
And with that I'm going to
invite the other two gentlemen
to come back up.
We'll answer whatever questions
you have.
Thanks.
Thanks for coming.
Mahe: So if you have questions,
just come to the mike.
Yes, we have one in back.
man: Where would you guys
fit tablets
into the desktop/mobile
paradigm?
Mahe: The question is,
where would we fit tablets
into the
desktop/mobile area?
Fletcher: That's a really
interesting question,
because you've got
more screen real estate,
but you don't necessarily
have the processing power,
the bandwidth, so you've got
to make those decisions
side by side,
on a case-by-case basis.
Mahe: I think
it's about your app.
If you're doing something
that's more mobile-ish,
like someone's got something
where I'm going to be
out in the world,
and you try and aim more
toward the mobile experience.
But if you're doing more
searching or planning
sort of stuff, you might try
to be able to shift
all the data
all over the place.
Fletcher: Another key point
to remember
is to not necessarily think
of this as a dichotomous thing.
Don't necessarily think of it
being desktop versus mobile,
because then as you say, where
does a tablet fit into this?
Think about it in terms of
the capabilities of the device
that the user
is viewing it on.
man:
Thank you.
man: Hi. Actually,
is there anything planned
for speed improvements
in terms of local caching for--
or, actually
there's a second question.
What is being done by you guys
in terms of vector-based
rendering of the map tiles,
or text on the map?
Mahe: The question is
what are we doing
about vector-based map tiles
in the API?
Fletcher: And the answer
is we can't comment
on any future plans or anything
like that, I'm afraid.
So I'm sorry
that's a non-answer.
Justin: It's a good question
though.
Mahe: It is a good question.
Yes.
woman: I thought
I saw some 3D mapping
in the honeycomb demos
where a certain gesture
would open up
a different type of map.
Could you comment on that,
and if that's available
for a desktop display?
Mahe: Not--
so the question was,
on the honeycomb tablet that
you've got the new maps with,
it's all threaded,
and you can spin around
and use gestures
and that sort of thing.
That won't be as part
of the API--
it's not delivered at the moment
as part of the API
sort of thing.
It kind of relates
to the vector style of maps,
and I don't think you can
at the moment
incorporate that mapping
into a native application
on the Android.
Yes, on desktop.
Well, that's part of the API
and those sorts of things,
and the answer is not yet.
Fletcher: Not at the moment.
man: When adding different types
of layers such as KML
and other types of
custom overlays,
you can't change the zed index
or whatever of the KML
to put it underneath
your other layers,
causing quite a big issue
if you want to have
a mashup of different
types of data.
Is that something you guys
are planning on fixing,
and one other small thing.
Are you planning on sorting--
at the moment,
KML behaves very differently
in Google Earth to on the Maps.
You lose a lot of functionality,
and in fact I've had--
we've had to pull it
from our site,
because it was
actually quite buggy
in terms of displaying
a large set of polygon data,
and you would click
on one polygon
and it would actually show data
for the other polygon.
Mahe: You want to repeat
the question.
Fletcher: So let me
get that right.
So there's two parts
to the question.
The first part was whether
it's possible to reorder
the layering that's done
through KML for example,
right down to the bottom.
Mahe: I'm not 100% sure.
If you'll see me after,
we'll be able to
find out for you.
Fletcher: And the second part
of the question was about--
Mahe: KML differences
between API and Earth.
Fletcher:
Ah, yes.
So KML was obviously
written for Earth,
and we only support a subset
of the features for it.
It doesn't really make sense
for most of the mapping
applications
to support the full subset,
because it just includes things
that don't make sense
on a two-dimensional map,
but that being said,
who knows?
We can't really comment
on future things
that might be coming up.
Mahe: I mean, if there's
anything in particular,
you can file a feature request,
or bug about specific bugs,
and then we can look at that.
Fletcher: And that's
a really good point
to bring up to the group.
If you have questions,
if you have feature requests,
file them with the group,
and that's where we sort
of look at things to do next.
Mahe:
Yeah.
Fletcher:
I think that's it.
Any other questions?
Mahe: Cool. Thank you.
Fletcher:
Okay, great. Thanks.
Justin:
Thank you.